les coup portés par le père de famille
ont valu à l'adolescent 10 jours dit
tétées incapacité totale de travail qui
a toujours nié tout implication mais qui
a quand même été mis en examen pour
agression sexuelle sur mineur de moins
de 15 ans donc monsieur qui était venu
présumé voilà venu dans sa maison voilà
placé en détention provisoires il a
porté plainte pour les polonaise à
graver donc le gars qui avait commis
priori un agression sexuelle a porté
plainte contre le papa pour violence
aggraver en réunion avec arme par
destination le papa était jugé avec
trois de ses amis aujourd'hui à Roanne
et si l'avocate demandait la relax le
procureur de la République a requis une
peine de 18 mois de prison donc 6 à 9
mois avec sursis probatoire pendant 2
ans la décision est mise en délibérée le
tribunal la rendra le 7 mars mais voilà
donc ils ont pris quand même 6 à 9 mois
avec sursis probatoire pendant deux ans
sur 6 probatoire pendant deux ans ça
veut dire que tu vas la rocher du char
c'est direct
à l'envers et qu'on a pas fait d'abord
on va voir ce que ça va là avec le
c'est parce que le jeune garçon
part aux assises alors que eux ne sont
pas aux assises c'est pour ça les procès
en acide
alors que le père de famille le message
est envoyé très message
envoyé les catastrophiques excusez-moi
mais c'est pas la même chose en plus
comment tu veux juger la deuxième
affaire le mec qui a rattrapé
l'agresseur présumée de sa fille sans
avoir jugé le gars qui aurait agressé
sexuellement sa fille non mais comment
tu fais non mais c'est n'importe quoi en
marche sur la tête mais il y en a ici
qui marche sur la tête
on marche sur la tête voilà non mais
voilà donc cette affaire parce que vous
en pensez de ce que ce skyrocki le
procureur de la République donc de 18
mois de prison 6 à 9 mois avec sursis
probatoire pendant deux ans
moi je trouve ça équilibré
[Applaudissements]
en plus ils ont individualisé ils
étaient quatre à être jugés il y en a un
qui a été relaxé il y en a un autre qui
était en état de récidive où il y a des
peines un peu plus lourdes requises donc
je trouve que c'est un jugement
équilibré et je suis désolé le procureur
l'avait dit avant on ne peut pas laisser
passer ça puisqu'on ne peut pas rendre
la justice
c'est quoi alors le oui c'est ce que
vous avez dit 18 mois de prison dans 6 à
9 avec sursis donc ça fait 9 à 12 mois
ça veut dire que la justice peut aller
vite bon évidemment c'est pour les
victimes plus établi vous dites
moi ce que tu veux que je te dise ce qui
est grave moi c'est que si
l'agresseur présumé est coupablement et
jugé coupable vous rendez compte qu'il a
quand même été
il était quand même non mais et si il a
été jugé après le papa qui s'est fait
dans
moi j'étais le premier ici à dire
justement il y aura peut-être une peine
encore plus grave pour le papa donc
c'est mal c'est mal fait bah oui c'est
donc ça marche dans les deux sens parce
que s'il est imaginons qu'il soit
innocent et ben le père il va prendre
encore plus puisqu'il est justement donc
donc là on va rien ça marche à l'envers
excuse-moi de te dire ça qu'est-ce que
tu en penses vraiment moi je trouve ça
scandaleux j'avais dit ici j'avais
décidé il n'avait pas à se faire justice
eux-mêmes il fallait pas attraper
quelqu'un dans la rue au hasard et le
frapper il m'avait dit c'est pas au
hasard cette nuit c'est lui c'est lui
vous savez pas si c'est lui j'avais été
décrié là je trouve ça dégueulasse de
passer d'abord lui en justice le père
qui s'est défendu en pensant que c'était
l'agresseur et l'agresseur il est
tranquillement on va dire tranquillement
il est en prison mais il a pas avoué il
ni il dit que c'est pas lui et on fait
le 300 à l'envers moi je suis d'accord
avec Kenny on fait le procès
complètement à l'envers ça ça valait
quoi d'attendre on attend et on juge pas
là avant l'autre
excusez-moi
puisque il y a une enquête très longue
et s'il ne l'est pas et s'il ne l'est
pas mais mais
une enquête très longue donc faisons une
enquête très longue pour les deux parce
que
en arrêtant ce contribuant à arrêter ce
jeune homme il a peut-être une fille de
6 ans excuse-moi c'est ça le plus
important
mais on va parler tranquillement parce
que j'ai l'impression que je on se
comprend pas le chinois avec vous non
mais c'est incroyable comment on peut
être aussi borné écoute-moi tu ne peux
pas juger un gars si tu ne sais pas si
il a retrouvé
l'agresseur de sa fille ou si ça n'était
pas l'agresseur de sa famille pas du
tout mais ça n'a rien à voir la peine va
être beaucoup plus pour lui si ça n'est
pas l'agresseur de sa fille mais Gilles
Verdez et Géraldine maillet vous êtes
encore dans la maison
c'est bien maman faut être de donner
faut être dans l'humain bien sûr je vois
un mec qui a accusé d'avoir violé une
enfant et un père de famille qui a juste
voulu défendre sa fille qui j'ai envie
du genre 1er le mec qui accéder à violer
l'enfant et l'autre question qu'il faut
se poser c'est qui est un danger pour la
société le mec qui est accusé d'avoir vu
les enfants là on est en train de faire
un mec qui était innocent un potentiel
criminel juste parce qu'il a défendu sa
fille excuse-moi
nous ce qu'on dit Géraldine la dernière
fois on avait demandé je me rappelle
voilà un procès rapide là au contraire
on se dit trou faisons long pour les
deux pour savoir tous les tonneaux et
les aboutissants de l'affaire pour
pouvoir juger le papa en même temps que
l'agresseur présumée je sais pas je
trouve que c'est c'est la logique
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Bernard non
ce qui est sûr c'est que on comprend
tout à fait la réaction du père c'est un
choc non mais il aurait jamais dû faire
ça évidemment que c'est ce que j'avais
dit la dernière fois c'est c'est
horrible ce qui est arrivé parce que
c'est arrivé de toute façon ça ça a été
reconnu que la petite fille a été
agressée sexuellement donc c'est une
horreur je peux comprendre que le mec en
colère il a envie de casser la gueule
alors c'est un voisin le monsieur qui a
été incriminé qui habite à 100 mètres de
cette maison mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
des lois et que c'est difficile en fait
là il est condamné non pas pour
enfin il est il y a une réquisition
contre lui etc simplement parce qu'il a
tabassé ce monsieur
c'est pas lié enfin c'est lié évidemment
mais c'est une autre affaire pour savoir
ce que pensait téléspectateurs continuer
le sondage là-dessus pour savoir
vraiment refusé la légitime défense
parce que l'agression de du présumé
coupable a eu lieu 24 heures après le
premier faible
et donc ça
le samedi donc le dimanche c'est bon
mais Géraldine
normalement a vu une photo qu'on lui a
montré sur la photo c'est un être humain
excuse-moi
on parle pas de vaccin calme-toi ma
chérie
je vais t'inviter sur Olivier Véran non
ça va te faire plaisir oh mais c'est
vrai ouais
tu aimes bien comme ça et à lui ce sera
toujours monsieur petitieux voilà c'est
comme ça voilà oui alors dans ce cas
précis le gars il est venu première fois
il était reconnu il revient là il
revient le le lendemain il se fait
ressort prendre honnêtement et moi je
vous dis honnêtement peut-être qu'on
peut pas se faire je sais ce soir même
mais leur mec en question je suis désolé
moi on rentrerait chez moi on ferait un
acte violence sexuel à mon fils mais je
peux te dire que je vais pas attendre 2
minutes que la police arrive si il est
chez toi
et je trouve ça scandaleux et perdez moi
le juge plus on met un sursis à statut
on attend de savoir ce qui s'est passé
exactement ce qu'on est en train de dire
mais il parle d'autre chose
très respectueusement pour une fois
Cyril vous commettez une grosse erreur
parce que je vous expliquez qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent patron du coup là
[Rires]
vous expliquer
pour juger quelqu'un qui est jugé pour
violence en réunion et c'est une erreur
que vous faites mais c'est normal rien à
voir que le jeune soit coupable ou pas
la peine et la même il y a pas de
causalité
tu peux comprendre un truc c'est
inadmissible
mais écoute-moi mais mais si tu non mais
écoute moi j'ai le droit de dire que je
trouve ça mais toi tu te remets mais toi
toi je t'explique toi toi on on pourrait
chier devant ta porte
non mais sans déconner sur ta tête tu
dirais bah c'est la loi regarde c'est
l'article il y a 90 non mais sans
déconner
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est tout à fait
normal
[Applaudissements]
une rupette de merde
franchement tu sais comme je t'aime
merci
[Rires]
j'adore
j'ai l'image maintenant
voilà bah voilà voilà
c'était des des
trucs en train de rigoler quoi ils ont
imaginé Gilles voilà